hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again this
is gonna be one of the longest videos I
think I've ever made in the most complex
video I've ever made to date for sure as
we talked about in my last video we
mentioned that there was gonna be a lot
of attack of nerves and the occasional
attack above because they're increasing
it / decreasing a lot of the damage with
the game by averaging it out and then
lowering the damage from there so I
decided that the most inhumane diss
stupidest decision I've ever made -
pretty much mark down just about every
move in this entire game and see how
they differentiate from the test server
which is testing grounds and the live
server which is what we use to play the
actual game two very important parts
though is that AI will be using the term
test like I said the testing grounds and
live being live server or what we
currently play in now throughout the big
part of the video so just to make things
a lot shorter than it needs to be and
also there of course will be timestamps
in the description if you want to find
your specific main although I do
recommend afterwards you keep the entire
video on and watched till the end the
whole 30 minutes just for that sweet
sweet you know watch time because
YouTube's gonna [ __ ] me on this video
for sure and then lastly I just want to
thank the three people yato
who helped me with the Knights Aires who
helped me with the Vikings and samurai
and Dragon who helped me with the Wulin
being my test dummy yeah like I said
timestamps in the description down below
and enjoy the video guys let me know if
you think peace out the first up of the
nights we have warden wardens top light
opener is 12 and his side lights are 12
except on the right it's 10 so top light
is 12 left side light is 12 and right
side is 10 I doesn't make much sense to
me either the live game is 15 and then
it's 12 on both sides so about a 2 to 3
damage nerf there his heavy openers are
26 on the top and 24 on the side
compared to 40 on the top and 30 on the
side so definitely some nerves they're
heavy finisher is 37 top 29 side live
servers are both 40 except member the
top is unblockable so of course the
actual duration of how long the move is
is a little different of course sprint
attack zone attack and valiant
breakthrough hour all 15 compared to the
live server which is 15 sprint 20 zone
and 20 valiant breakthrough so volume
break there ends
got nerfed by 5 damage crushing counter
is 25 I'm not sure what this is on live
but I think it's 40 so definitely a nerf
there and the double light combo is 12
on the first hit four on the second from
left and 10 on the first hit on the
right and four on the second hit on the
right compared to 15 to 6 on both sides
on the live server so quick recap nerf
to pretty much everything except sprint
attack which stayed the same stuff as
Konkan remember he has an infinite chain
of lights and heavy so his light openers
are 12 on the on the live server those
are 13 the test server light combos are
12 as well but the combos on live are 18
so nerf there for heavies it's 14 on the
top and 22 on the side with on the live
being 33 on the top and 25 on the side
for the combos it's 29 to the right 30
to the left and 32 to the top I don't
know either
and for the combos it's also just 30 on
life the unblockable charged heavy is 35
on the side and 37 on the top with the
live being 33 side 44 top respectively
uppercut got nerfed it is now 16 as
opposed to 30 and for the zone the first
swing is 8 they're following ones are
four as opposed to it being 10 and then
to 5 so recap Connor in every part for
peacekeeper her light opener on the top
is 14 and then on the side is 13 the
live is just 15 both sides then we have
the chain which technically is the exact
same for both categories so 14 top 13
side on the test server and 15 on the
live so doesn't matter no valleys have
changed their heavy opener is 26 on the
top 24 on the side and for the live
server this is 23 on the top and 20 to
the side heavy finishers are both 29 on
the test server and then are also both
27 on the live server so damage
increased the heavies decreased the
lights the zone attack is a 15 on the
first hit in a 21 on the second on the
live server this is 15 then 20 so a 1
damage increase on the second hit PK's
forward dodge attack is 18 and then this
side is 19 on the live these are both 17
so a bit of an increase on those and
then her bleed attacks on all aspects
dagger cancel deflect gb bleed and deep
gouge are all the exact same for both
tests so the light attack Scott's of
nerf
heavy attacks got some buffs the bleed
is the exact same and the zone is one
day image a bit higher same with the
dodges being a little bit higher so next
up is la burger and remember he has a
starter a chain and a finisher starter
being the first moves chains being the
second and he finishers being the third
for both lights and heavies for the
lights his top is 11 and side is 12 on
and on live it's 15 on so of course
there's going to be a nerf there but the
chain it's the exact same thing top is
11 side is 12 and then on the live it's
also 15 so really no change between
those two but the light finishers it is
14 on the test and 20 on live but it's
20 on top and 18 on the side regardless
it's a nerf from both sides just depends
on how big the nerf is for the Heavy's
it's 26 top 24 side live it's 30 all
round the chains it's 29 top 27 side and
then the live it's 35 top 30 side so
more nerfs heavy finisher aka the
unblockable heavy is 29 to the side 30
top or on the live it's 35 side and 40
top the Sprint attack is 8 instead of 10
the zone is 17 from neutral 18 from a
Perry aka the unblockable we're on live
it's 20 neutral 22 parried speaking of
Perry punishes the top heavy unblockable
is 39 which of course like I said it
from the top we're on live it's 30 so an
increase there the side heavy which is
that riposte Perry is now 8 instead of 5
and that light rip off that quick 200
millisecond light is now 14 as opposed
to 15 on the live so so nervous
everywhere except the two heavy Perry
punishes being the top and the side for
Centurion he also has three hit combos
as well so for his lights his chain his
starter and his finisher it's 12:00
12:15 across the board in every
direction whereas on live it's actually
backwards starter is 15 chain as 12 and
finisher is 12 so just flip the numbers
around her heavy opener and finisher
they're the same at 20 and on live it's
also the same but at 25 so a 5 damage
nerf for the charged member there's the
unblockable variant and then there's the
regular one that's blockable but of
course it's charged for just the regular
blockable it's 28 but 33 is unblockable
and I believe on the live it's just 34
both so no reason to really complicate
this the zone is the exact same at 75
damage total but 25 each hit the Sprint
attack is 28 on the test server and 20
on live and eagle talon is 33 tests and
35 on live
so overall the Sprint attack got a buff
the charged heavy got a nerve slash buff
depending on whether it's blockable or
not and then the rest of it was a nerf
the gladiator his opener lights are 14
the chains are 14 on the top and then 13
on the side all throughout the rest of
the combo up until the end for life this
is just 15 in any direction at any point
just I don't know why they had to
complicate it
gladiators heavies are 24 on the top 26
on side with the live of being just 30
and then for the finishers it's 29
everywhere and then once again 30 on the
live as well so a little bit of a damage
decrease there again for the dodge
attacks the side in the top are 14 for
the test and 20 on live so another nerf
toe stab is now 8 damage instead of 10
his own attack is now 27 on the test and
20 on live servers not including the
damage that you get from the stamina
stuff and haymaker just the regular
second attack at the end sprint attack
is 21 on test 15 on live and I think
skewer is the same from neutral and
deflect but honestly I can't really
calculate the bleed regardless though
it's 20 damage from the attack when you
do it and I believe on live servers it's
like 2 but if it's not it's pretty much
the exact same so there's no worries
there regardless though the skewer
physical damage seems to be a buff the
bleed is the exact same and then other
than that everything else was a nerf
besides the Sprint attack and the zone
which got buffs lastly for the Knights
we have black prior the light openers
are 12 on all sides for live it's 15 for
his finishers they're 14 and then on
live their 17 for the heavy openers
they're 26 top 24 side on the live it's
35 top 30 side for the finishers it's 29
on all sides which is that undable one
and then on the live this is 35 dash
forward heavy is 20 just like the same
it is on live and then the full block we
have the unblockable heavy which is 29
in the test 30 in live servers and then
the flip is also the exact same at 30 so
pretty much nerfs by a 1 or 3 damage
except the heavy finishers which are at
6 damage and
the flip is the exact same for a quick
recap there next up is writer and
remember he has the three hit combo so
we're gonna be doing the chains these
starters than the chains and the
finishers from the top these are twelve
twelve fourteen on live it's 15 15 22 on
the side it's twelve twelve seventeen
whereas on live this is 15 15 18 for the
Heavy's it's 28 32 34 from the top on
live this is a very tremendous nerf to
40 40 45 that was the original values on
the side it's 26 27 29 live is 35 35 40
first to sprint attacks you have then
you have that like charge and then you
have the heavy the heavy is 20 on test
35 on live and the knee is the exact
same the neutral zone is 20 and in
chains it's 44 but on the live from
neutral it's 28 and in chains it's 44
storming tap is now 12 in the test and
15 on live so once again nervous across
the board except the chains own and knee
being the exact same for warlord his
light openers are 13 on the top 12 on
site on live this is 18 top 15 side
finishers it's 14 all around the sides
and on live the finishers are 18 top 15
side as well for heavy openers it's 24
top 26 side whereas on live it's 30 top
35 side heavy finisher is 26 on all
sides and on live it's 35 on the top and
40 on the side so once again nervous and
all those sections but they depend they
vary a little bit in number depending on
what side you're throwing it for his
dodge attacks since it's the exact same
as his Sprint that's 24 in the test and
35 in the live servers the untouchable
heavy from that full block is 18 on live
this is 30 and then for the light jab
from full block this is 17 on live this
is actually 15 so nerfs everywhere once
again except light from the full block
Berserker has an infinite chain ranging
from lights to heavy still lights the
heavies back and forth so for the
starters in terms of lights it's 15 from
all sides and when in a chain it's going
to be 13 on live this is 15 whether it
be starter or chain for heavies it's 31
on the top
twenty-eight on the side with the chain
being in 25 so in the middle of a combo
we're on live this is 38 top 33 side and
then the 25 damage is still the same
when in a chain for the heavy
unblockable it is 36 on test 30 on live
for the zone forward zone it's 5 times 4
so 20 overall we're on live this is 6
times 4 so 24 4 backwards I believe this
was 28 totals or 7 times 4 and on the
live it's 32 or 8 times for the Sprint
attack is just the same as the side
heavy so 28 on the test 33 live for the
dashes the - forward light is 15 and the
side - is 16 and the heavy forward - is
28 on live this is 17 17 25 respectively
and then the parry punishes the exact
same at 17 overall the parry punish is
the same and the heavy forward - is a
buff as well as the heavy unblockable
getting a buff everything else was also
a nerf Valkyrie once again has those
triple attack so we're gonna do starter
chain - finisher from the sides in the
top for a light top it's 12 11 13 live
is 15 13 12 side light is 12 12 14 and
this on live is 15 1310 heavies from the
top is 24 27 29 the live is 28 30 32
side is 24 27 29 and the live is 28 30
32 forward - is 12 and the side - is 13
on the live servers this is 17 for both
sides the heavy after the sweep is the
exact same at 35 in the shoulder pin is
12 damage plus 25 bleed we're on live
it's 20 damage plus 25 bleats a little
bit of a nerf their sprint attack is 22
but on live it's 20 so a buff to the
Sprint attack and zone is 17 first hit
11 second hit we're live it's just 20 20
so overall still once again I to the
zone for shaman her light opener on all
sides is 11 and on live this is 10 her
double light is 11 and then 5 on the
second hit we're on live this is 15 then
5 heavy openers are 28 on all sides
we're on live this is 27 33 is
finishers on the test and 32 is on life
the unblockable heavy though is 35 in
the test and 40 in live soap still a
nerf the zone is 12 8 8 8 instead of 15
10 15 10 so overall it's 36 in total on
the test and 50 on the live servers four
dashes the top attack is 20 in the side
is 18 on live this is 20 on all sides
the blood is the exact same at 50 damage
deflected is 20 then 16 but live is 15
then 16 bleed bleed after chains is 15
damage than a 16 bleed tick whereas on
live this is 1 damage plus 16 bleed tick
nerfs everywhere though except bleed
stabs on deflect and chains and on the
Sprint the tech for Highlander the light
openers are 13 on all sides and then on
the live it's 15 for heavy openers it's
28 on all sides but for live it's a bit
different with 45 top and 35 sites and
once again still a nerf but really hurts
depending on what side it is at for
finishers it's 28 on the top and 29 on
the side and I live it's 35 so once
again still a nerf the zone is a 3 hit
and it's 19 24 24 but on live it's 25 25
25 the Sprint attack is 24 17 or on live
it's 25 20 calcic curse is 24 from the
top and 23 on side on the live it's 25
in all directions in offensive stance
your side lights are gonna do 8 damage
your top lights are gonna do 9 on the
live this is 10 in every direction for
the heavies it's 31 on all sides and on
the live it's 40 on all sides crush
encounter is 25 and all sides and I
think on live this is 30 so pretty much
nurse all around I believe I may have
gotten a couple numbers wrong at least I
do remember all of them being nerfs did
they all just vary depending on what
number they are and then lastly for the
Vikings we have your the light openers
are 12 on all sides on live this is 16
for the finishers it's 14 and then on
live that's 18 for heavy openers it's 26
top 24 side on the live it's 30 top 25
sides of still a nerf finishers is 29
all sides and on live it's 30 all sides
so once again
nerf but only one damaged dodge attack
is also a one-point buff dodge attack is
26 damage this is 25 on live the zone
attack is 12 live is 25 sprint is 20
live is 18 and then the nut bust is the
exact same as it is on the live servers
which is that 50 on to the third faction
the samurai and just start with the
samurai we have Ken say and once again
the triple attack so in order we have
starter chain and finisher will be doing
top and side football flights and
heavies so from starter chain and then
finisher from light top it is 12 12 14
on live it's 18 everywhere on the side
it's 12 12 14 as well on live this is 15
15 18 on the heavies it's 28 32 39 from
the top we're on live it's 40 40 45 the
side is 26 27 32 on live this is 40 30
35 for the dashes the dash light aka
helm splitter is 12 and then the side
bash heavy is 18 and then the nature's
wrath is 22
whereas on live - light or Helms
splitter is 17 and then it's 20 on both
nature's rather than - heavies the zone
is 15 15 on live this is 20 20 and then
the Sprint is the exact same so once
again some nerves but they vary in terms
of number for show go key has light
openers are 12 on live it's 15 for heavy
openers it's 24 on live this is 34
finishers it's 19 on live this is 35
now for the unblockable variation for
the charged version for the openers it's
41 all side from live it's top of 50 and
then side is 45 for the finishers it's
40 on all sides and then 45 top 40 on
side for live so some small changes
there especially the 40 on the side for
the finisher is the exact same on the
side of at the top it's a nerf very very
different there but for the Sprint it's
the exact same at 20 the zone is 16 on
the test 20 on live the hug is the exact
same as both at 25 and the golf swing
ache a demon ball is 29 but on live it's
25 so a buff there for oaties light
openers these are 12 and 14 the live is
12 and 5
team for finishers it's 15 on top 16 on
side for live it's 15 top 17 side for
the heavy opener it's 25 on top 28 on
side for live this is 35 top 30 side for
finishers it's 30 on top 33 on side with
the live having 35 on top and 30 on side
the zone is 21 and sprint is 16 we're on
live its 20 zone and 17 sprint so the
sprint does one less damage on the test
servers for the dashes they are as
follows the dash forward light is 15 and
then the side dashes are 16
whereas on live these are 17 all around
for Riptide strike it is 22 same as it
is on live storm Rush is 15 from the
right 16 on the left and 17 from the top
whereas on the live servers it is 17 all
around light deflect is 29 more on live
it's 25 and heavy deflect is 35 the live
is 50 the last thing I forgot to add for
Orochi was his chain double light which
is 12 and 6 which is the exact same on
live as it is in the test server
mabushii was a little bit complicated so
let's break this down a bit light
openers were 12 on all sides the live
was 15 the heavy openers were 28 all
sides
live was 32 and then the finisher heavy
was 30 on all sides with the live being
35 her triple light bleed combo is 30
damage than 12 bleed live was 40 damage
14 bleed - light is 13 damage plus 12
bleed from the top and then the live is
6 plus 12 lead her - heavy her
Sidewinder I believe it's called is 18
damage on the live it's 25 her Sprint
attacks she has a heavy and a light
version the heavy is 14 and the light is
17 whereas on lie of this the heaviest
17 and the light is 18 for her zone it's
15 and 21
whereas live it's 20 and 21 for back
step or Vipers retreat it's 14 damage
plus 12 bleed on live at 6 plus 12 lead
and then we remember the fact that no
boo she has those weird traits where she
gets extra damage when the opponent is
bleeding so a quick TL DR she does three
extra damage on lead attacks five extra
damage on heavies for extra damage on
dashes and three extra damage on the
light
specifically we're shinobi the light
opener is 12 on all sides live is 14
heavy opener is 28 all sides live is 30
and then the heavy finisher is 30 l
sides live is 35 for the double light
it's twelve then six but on the live
servers it's 14 then ten zone attack is
sixteen at four eight whereas live it's
ten five ten so basically in total these
own attack is twenty eight on test live
is 25 charged heavy is twenty eight on
all sides the live is twenty five
deflect is twenty five bleed then the
follow-up eight light damage if you
choose to do that whereas on live is
twenty five bleed as well but the light
attack is fifteen the parry light is
sixteen damage then they following
fifteen bleed we're on the live it's
fourteen damage than a fifteen bleed
sickle rain obviously the combo depends
on what kind of heavies you use whether
it be open or a finisher but in terms of
the bleed itself it is six light damage
for the three hit so two each and then
twelve bleed as same as live for our
emotions those weird chains as well so
they're kind of infinite so let's go
over that the light openers are twelve
on all side and in a chain the light
attack is twelve on live it's fifteen
and for the opener but if they're in a
chain attack they're seventeen for
heavies they have chain and start as
well so for the top it's twenty in the
start but twenty-two if in a chain for
the live it's twenty-five then twenty
eight but on side it's 20 to start
twenty-five chain with live being forty
start in thirty three chain finishers on
all sides are 32 we're on the live it's
45 side forty top sprint is twenty and
then the 22 on both the moves cuz you
can double it if you [ __ ] up the first
one but on live it's just 25 for the
zone it's 15 then 24 whereas live is
just fifteen thirty fives for the dashes
the top heavy is 18 and the side heavy
is twenty on the live it's just 24 both
and for the full block is a couple
variations as usual so heavy side is
going to be 27 on live this is 40 and
for the top heavy it is 16 the live is
thirty so pretty significant nerfs on
the full block and then lastly we have
heat so kiri for the samurai the light
opener is 12 on all sides we have live
which is eight
her finishers are 14 on the live this is
18 as well for the heavy openers there
are 24 and the finishers are 25 but on
live they're all 28 so I decrease by
about 3 or 4 depending on which one you
use for charged
it's 34 up for the unblockable but on
live this is 40 so a six damage nerf her
- attack is 30 the same as on live her
sprint and zone attack are 20 damage on
live servers these are 30 sprint and 20
zones who endure - the Sprint attack and
even though of course she has variable
heavy timings her damage is still the
same for both alive in the test
respectively so there isn't any weird
[ __ ] in between and last but not least
we have the woven or finally towards the
end of today's video and first up we're
gonna start out with the Vanguard T on D
so his light openers on the test server
are 12 on live this is 15 and 14 from
the side so with the 12 being all around
the finishers are 13 all sides with them
on live being 1514 so no real changes
from the live but of course the test
server has just one extra damage for the
heavy openers they're 26 on top 24 on
the side on alive this is 35 on the top
37 on the side with the heavy finishers
being 26 in both directions and the test
server with the live server having 30 on
the top 37 side so definitely a decrease
in damage the Sprint attack on the test
is 22 the live is 25 zone attack is a 2
hit in its 15 first 22 second with the
live server being 20 then 25 t has the 4
- attacks the light top inside and then
the heavy top inside and fourth at the
light top is 12 D side light is 13 on
the live server this is just 12 all
round with the Heavy's the top is 22 and
the side is 26 because that of course is
a lot longer and it hits a lot harder
but on the live server it's 20 and then
25 xiaolin he has the death point strike
which we'll get into in a second on the
light openers the very top hit is 11
with death point strike its 666 because
it is three hits with them on being on
the live server it's actually one damage
more so it's 12 from the top and 777
from these sides the finisher for the
top is 14 and of course
death point strike is that point strike
nothing has changed there but the
finisher for the top light is actually
18 on live server so once again a
decrease in damage for heavy openers
it's 24 on all sides this is 25 on live
for the heavy finishers the exact same
thing 24 live where this is a bigger
decrease with it being at 35 on the live
servers for the - attack city has his
top - is 20 and his side is 18 whereas
on live this is 25 and 20 of course
Shaolin has key stance and a lot of
things he can do with in key stance so
to go over that really quickly his top
light is 9 damage and his side light is
11 from key except in the live game it's
just 18 the top heavy is 33 and the side
a heavy which is that undoubtable
property is 28 where isn't alive this is
40 and 30 the Sun kick into light is 20
and then that heavy right after the kick
is 28 on live this is 20 to 35 for
deflect end zone to finish it off the
deflect is 21 on live this is 25 and
since he has a three part zone the
damage is 1010 twelve adding up to 32
with the other being 1010 20 which adds
up to 40 on the live server so an 8
damage decrease for a new show she has
three hit combo so be already know what
we're gonna do we're gonna go over that
again so the triple light combo from all
the top is fourteen thirteen fifteen
this is the exact same thing on the left
side and right side as well so the exact
same property with the triple heavy from
the side and the top being the exact
same of 28 31 33 on the live servers the
lights are thirteen thirteen eleven and
the heavies are thirty thirty-five forty
so definitely a decrease in damage there
for the zone attack it's thirty one
damage on live this is twenty five so
when increase in damage her - top is 15
and her side - is fifteen as well on the
test server bought on live this is 20
and then seventeen her Sprint attack is
the same at twenty and then she has the
deflect and parry punish her deflect is
twenty nine and Perry is 22 where his
deflect on live servers is 40 and Perry
is 20 so an increase and a decrease for
both of them being fluctuated a bit she
also has the to trap moves the heavy
trap so heavy in
pull it in then trap is 28 whereas if
you do the trap during the zone it's 41
we're on live servers this is 30 and 45
so once again decrease in damage
next up is jayjay and for light openers
it's 12 on top 18 on side wear for the
live it's just fully 18 everywhere the
same exact thing goes for the finishers
being 12 top 18 side and then 18
everywhere on the live servers her heavy
openers it's 26 top and 32 side with
this being 37 38 respectively on live
servers for the heavy finishers which of
course has the unblockable property it
is actually 28 top 32 side wear on the
live it is 33 35 so once again decreases
their sprint attack is a two hit attack
and it's 22 21
whereas in live this is 25 20 so a buff
to the second part but a nerf to the
first part zone he has three different
zones thankfully all of them do the same
damage on both live and test except the
numbers of course different on the test
it's 16 and on the live it's 25 but all
three of the zone attacks for their
respective tests or live servers they do
the exact same damage JJ has three dash
attacks technically the top is 26 the
dash is 23 and then the saw Fey and
light from the - I believe was 14
whereas on live servers both of the
dashes from right or top or left or
whatever happens to be is 25 and I
believe the saw faint is 15 coming down
to the very very end of the video today
we have soon de or Zhan who to end its
and his light openers are 12 on top 15
on side where this is the exact same as
his finishers and on the live server
this is 15 top 18 side once again same
exact thing for his finishers same is
going to be happening for the heavies
the heavy opener and the heavy finisher
are both 24 on the top 32 on the side
whereas on the live servers both the
heavy opener and finisher are 30 on top
and 35 on the side so very simple and
respectable math soon die has all the
sorts of dash attacks his dash attack
top light is 11 and his side light is 12
whereas on live this is 14 both soon as
dash attack top heavy is 20 and his side
heavy is 12 because technically it has
light attack property so it is still a
12 damage light
whereas on live this is 25 from the top
and 14 from the side his own attack does
16 damage in the test but 20 on live and
the Sprint attack is the exact same at
20 yes for making this far in the video
I'm pretty sure this is like a 30 minute
video by this definitely one of my
longer videos I think the longest video
I've ever made this took a hell of a lot
of processing and editing to do had to
come up with all the different logos in
the names and the text everywhere so if
we leave a like and subscribe if you're
new if may it put a lot of work into
this video be a with that guys I'm not
gonna keep you here any longer like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe for new if
you want to know where this stuff came
from it came from my past video which
you can check out at the end of this
video it's gonna talk about in a more
simplistic idea of what the is actually
happening I just covered a big majority
of one of the parts that being the
attack nerfs Bay as always liked the
view doings like a subscriber free new I
cover the informational side a foreigner
that being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to catch this David with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out an update
don't free subscribe the channel
bye guys take care girls today peace out
and goodbye
[Music]
you